this installation by nigerian born
artist Oh Lonnie Rashida India is made
from everyday materials such as
cardboard fabric and plastic the work is
an existential reflection of
post-colonial Africa combined with
political and environmental issues it's
a vivid complex creation representing
human interconnectedness the artist who
lives in the United States says he's
also interested in questions about
African self representation how can we
find a way to poetry to sell African as
we really are not what people portray
toes so at this time my one of my
website I'm presenting a disease vision
is called portrait the work of victory
he common or another nigerian artist
deals with the stark changes in his
country he grew up in a society largely
influenced by mythology and religion his
installation is a kind of prayer room
that recreates the world of his
childhood you know places like this they
are all going esting now you probably
won't find them anymore but I was lucky
enough as it kids to find places like
this where people could go for prayers
could good for divination could good for
prophecy you know so that is what I've
recreated here and the sculpted
paintings are representation of people
that go in there the kind of clothes
they would weird kind of colors that is
vibrant as traditions give way to
technology some old ways of life are
dying out while new lifestyles are still
being defined these are the kinds of
questions about transition posed by the
artist at the dock art biennale in
Senegal